bonjour à tous je m'appelle romain
charles et aujourd'hui je vous parle est
un petit peu de mon expérience j'ai vu
qu'il y avait beaucoup de d'étudiants
dans cette salle et donc je parlé un
petit peu d'un d'un projet enfin mme oda
d'un projet d'un parcours de vie et
essayer d'en tirer quelques conclusions
c'est étonnant parce que dans toutes les
personnes que j'ai eu avant moi beaucoup
de mots importants de mots clés ont été
dit et répété et donc je l'espère en
tout cas je pouvoir aller répéter pour
vous tous ce soir
alors déjà aujourd'hui je suis là parce
que j'ai fait des choix qui m'ont emmené
dans des contrées un petit peu étrange
et il je vais vous demander de remonter
un peu dans le temps pour suivre un
petit peu le ce parcours on est en
octobre 2009
je suis ingénieur qualité dans
l'automobile et suite à la sélection des
astronautes de 2009
j'ai cette passion du spatial que
j'avais en tant qu' en tant
qu'adolescent qui revient et j'ai envie
de me rapprocher un petit peu de ce
monde qui me fait rêver
du coup je regarde les offres et là un
jour je vois sur le site de l'agencé
spatiale européenne
un appel à candidats pour la mission
mars 500 pour simuler un voyage aller
retour vers la planète mars mars
on est resté sur terre quand même et je
me dis c'est intéressant et je postule
après avoir postulé
j'en parle un peu ma famille est là ma
famille mes amis
il regarde certains amis disent subir
c'est un super projet vas-y on est tous
derrière toi
mais tous les autres et les plus proches
de moi ont 10 mai mais pourquoi pourquoi
est ce que tu voulais aller t'enfermer
si longtemps et aussi loin c'était à
moscou l'expérience est en fait pour
cette sélection je pense que c'est
quelque chose qui m'a beaucoup servi
parce que dès le début il a fallu que
j'explique aux personnes les plus
proches de moi pourquoi je pensais que
ce projet fou était bon bon d'un point
de vue scientifique a essayé de faire
avancer mettre la petite brique sur le
chemin qui nous emmène vers la planète
mars est bon pour moi une façon très
égoïste
east pour me rapprocher de ce rêve cette
passion du spatial que j'avais et du
coup je me suis lancé dans cette
sélection et à chaque étape
je donnais tout ce que j'avais et
souvent c'est un petit peu par exemple
pour le questionnaire internet que l'on
avait au tout début il était demandé est
ce que vous connaissez le russe répondu
oui quelques mois plus tard j'arrive à
au jury donc j'avais huit personnes en
face de moi pour un entretien
psychologique et là sur 7
sur ces huit personnes deux russes et
l'âge et la peur au ventre je me dis si
l'un des deux me pose une question en
russe c'est fini c'est fini pour moi il
ya un moment le couperet est tombé
une des deux personnes ça m'a demandé
oui on a vu que vous avez marqué par que
vous menez c'est le russe est ce que
vous pouvez nous dire une petite phrase
je dis ah mais non en fait je ne parle
pas russe est juste que je connais la
russie j'y suis allé avec mon frère donc
je connais un petit peu la russie et hop
on est passé à la question suivante ce
qui m'a permis quand même de passer une
étape de plus et une étape plus une
étape plus une étape au final trois
semaines avant le début de la mission
j'ai été sélectionnée pour faire partie
de l'équipage de marc 500 alors trois
semaines c'est pas beaucoup donc il a
fallu que je quitte mon boulot que je
quitte tout le monde pour rentrer dans
ces modules de mars 500 alors j'ai juste
prendre un pas en arrière pour vous
expliquer un petit peu ce que c'est
quand même se marrent 500 mars500 c'est
donc une simulation d'un voyage
aller-retour vers la planète mars
mais c'est une mission scientifique
l'idée c'est de poser une grande
question est d'essayer d'y répondre
cette grande question c'est est-ce que
l'homme psychologiquement et
physiquement est capable d'endurer le
confinement d'un voyage vers mars
en d'autres mots est ce qu'on est
capable de passer un an et demi dans un
dans des modules hermétiquement clos
sens tu es est toujours en travaillant
efficacement ensemble donc spoiler alert
la réponse est oui
et donc voilà ça c'était un peu marre
500 voilà l'équipage finale qui a été
sélectionné vous voyez qu'on ait 6 6
hommes avec trois russes
notre commandant centre en bas alex et
city of je suis sûr que vous pouvez tous
lire son nom juste à sa droite donc à
gauche en bas sur la photo soukhrob
kamolov qui était notre médecin de bord
juste au dessus notre commandant
alexandre smolevski qui lui aussi était
médecin en haut à gauche
20 new est un chercheur en physiologie
du centre d'entraînement des astronautes
chinois et à droite les deux membres
européens qui avaient été sélectionnés
par l' agence spatiale européenne a dit
gurria en bas et moi même tous les deux
ingénieurs
voilà un petit peu l'équipage avec qui
j'ai passé un an et demi dans ces
modules
ces modules vous imaginez un petit peu à
quoi il ressemble ce que j'appelle un
module c'est un grand cylindre
métallique donc hermétiquement clos sans
fenêtre et il y en avait trois
principaux le plus grand c'était le
module de stockage
parce qu'on a besoin de beaucoup de
nourriture pour simuler un tel voyage
le deuxième qui était le plus important
pour nous c'était le module de vie qui
avait à peu près la taille d'un bus faut
imaginer et dans ce bus faut imaginer
six chambres une salle de contrôle
une salle de bains une cuisine et une
salle et le troisième module lui était
le module médical qui était un petit peu
notre module de travail
alors avant de venir à notre travail
jésus tour a ajouté que ces trois
modules là on n'y a eu accès pendant un
an et demi mais en plein milieu de notre
voyage ce que c'est quand même un aller
retour vers la planète mars mars
on a eu accès un atterrisseur martiens
et pendant un mois on a pu avoir une
nouvelle pièce ce qui était génial mais
bon voilà
les membres de l'équipage
à quoi ressemble mars500 qu'est ce qu'on
a fait à l'intérieur c'est une
expérience scientifique
donc on a fait des expériences
scientifiques ont avalé 105 expériences
à faire et parce que les scientifiques
voulaient voir une évolution
eh bien on devait les faire
refaire il est offert donc voila un
petit peu notre travail au quotidien
les expériences les plus présentes et
les expériences psychologiques qui
s'intéressait à notre humeur qui
s'intéressait à façon d'apprendre des
choses
quel est l impact de ce confinement il y
avait aussi beaucoup d'expérience
physiologique qui s'intéressait à notre
corps de façon assez générale très
générale d'ailleurs et puis d'autres
d'autres expériences opérationnelles ou
médicale et dans ces modules lorsque je
suis rentré donc voilà pour bien un
petit peu comment j'ai survécu
une des choses que j'ai fait
consciemment en rentrant dans ces
modules et qui je pense m'a servi tout
au long ces deux consciemment me dire
voilà maintenant ça c'est ton univers et
tout ce que tu ne peux pas faire pour le
moment
eh bien tu feras dans un an et demi et
c'est arrivé il ya eu des moments comme
ça je me souviens d'une fois où je
regrettais de ne pas avoir eu un
enregistrement particulier je ré
imaginait et j'avais très envie
d'entendre le son du vent dans un champ
de blé j'allais souvent l'été chez mon
oncle au temps de la moisson est en
attente dans un champ y avait aucun
bruit y avait juste ce vent qui passait
et se sont liés à ce souvenir j'aime
vraiment envie de l'entendre n'y avait
pas moyen je dis moi quand je rentre je
vais aller voir mon oncle ça va être
génial et en fait après quelques heures
après quelques jours ses envies
disparaît scène et on pouvait continuer
comme ça la mission alors il ya eu des
moments plus ou moins difficiles et la
chose qu'il fallait le plus combattre
pendant cette mission c'était la
monotonie puisque bas on voyait toujours
les mêmes personnes n'avaient pas
internet puisque on simule est le délai
de communication avec la terre et est
pour pour battre et de monopoly on avait
plusieurs activités mais les moments les
plus difficiles
il vient en particulier que j'aimerais
écrire c'était un an après être rentré
dans les modules moi ça faisait déjà
douze mois comme nos modules
on était tous les six ensembles on ne
pouvait plus communiquer avec
l'extérieur
vous pouvez quand même envoyé des
messages qui étaient envoyés aux centres
de contrôle et ensuite sur internet
s'est envoyé à nos amis à notre famille
et c'est un peu comme si on envoyait des
lettres au siècle dernier et un an après
notre entrée tout le monde
la famille les amis les journalistes
nous écrivait nous envoyer des messages
en disant c'est super ça fait un an que
vous êtes dedans c'est génial elle
particulier les journalistes faisaient
et racontez nous un petit peu qu'est ce
qui s'est passé pendant cette année
comment est ce que vous prévoyez les 155
jours qui vous reste à tenir et
réfléchir à ce qui s'est passé pendant
un an c'est aussi repensé à tout ce
qu'on a loupé à l'extérieur pendant ces
1 an et ce n'est pas forcément agréable
et de réfléchir à 155 jours c'est plus
de cinq mois donc c'est pas c'est pas
anodin comme comme comme période non
plus et je m'en suis rendu compte
seulement après cette période avait plus
difficile j'étais moins patients j'avais
plus de mal tout simplement parce que
involontairement toutes ces questions
ces réflexions nous avait en tout cas
m'avait obligé à regarder cette
expérience dans sa totalité
on était habitué à vivre au jour le jour
chaque jour ces problèmes on a toujours
beaucoup d'activités en ne cédant avoir
le plus possible pour justement rester
dans le présent et on réfléchit c'est
une semaine en avance avec toutes les
expériences qu'on avait à préparer pour
les joueurs qui venaient mais jamais sur
la totalité de ses 1 an et demi et donc
ça ça a eu un impact et mais
heureusement notre équipage on a on n'a
jamais perdu quelque chose c'était les
communications les uns avec les autres
on a tous eu des hauts et des bas
c'était par vagues on a eu des moments
heureusement pas tous sont maintenant au
même moment et les autres membres
d'équipage ont permis aux uns et aux
autres de tenir et d'avancé et un jour
plus un jour plus un jour plus un jour
on arrive à 520 jours
donc voilà on était rentré le 3 juin
2010 et le 4 novembre 2011
on a pu enfin sortir de nos modules mars
500 i
l'histoire ne s'arrête pas là à la
sortie de nos modules déjà ça a été une
vraie découverte
ça a été génial d'une part parce que
notre famille nos amis a été là étaient
présents physiquement
d'autre part parce qu'il y avait de la
nourriture fraîche quelque chose qu'on
n'avait pas vu depuis un an et demi
c'était génial et assez rapidement on a
été envoyé vers un hôpital en
quarantaine et pendant le voyage en
voiture on s'émerveille et sur toutes
les choses qu'on voyait autour de nous
on était au final sont regardés au
regard d'un chien aulas un bébé toutes
ces choses là qu'on n'avait pas vu
depuis si longtemps on s'en émerveiller
de nouveau et je me souviens encore le
lendemain matin on devait se lever tôt
pour faire des prélèvements de sang en
cours les expériences et est là le
soleil s'est levé et je me souviens on
est encore dans les émotions j'imagine
de toutes les couleurs de ce lever de
soleil qui est passé entre deux blocs
d'immeubles à moscou et qui reste est si
beau et en fait après simple l'agencé
spatiale européenne nous a fait revenir
diego et moi en europe et a commencé
premièrement par rallonger notre contrat
c'était plutôt une bonne chose pour moi
parce que bon quand même
initialement gisela j'aimerais bien
travailler du côté du spatial et nous a
envoyé par monts et par vaux
on a fait des présentations de mars500
un travail sur des rapports on a été
dans les différents centres de lézat et
ça a été encore génial c'était quelque
chose qui te semblait irréel
des fois des amis me demandaient qu'est
ce que ça fait de retrouver une vie
normale
non non je pense pas que ce soit normal
encore en ce moment et puis si on après
les un autre chef avec nous voir on se
dit ah merci merci les gars c'était
super mais voilà au revoir et la ville
et je me suis retrouvé donc sans travail
et ce qui était initialement
voilà un projet un risque je les prix
bon ça n'a pas payé directement
heureusement je vous rassure grâce au
réseau grâce à toutes les personnes avec
qui j'avais pu travailler j'ai pu être
recruté pour devenir support des
astronautes européens parce que j'ai pu
vivre
confiné pendant si longtemps et sont du
bon il doit pouvoir comprendre un petit
peu ce que les astronautes vivre
lorsqu'ils sont là haut dans la station
spatiale internationale qui doit être un
peu plus de 100 milliards je pense
maintenant et qui est donc ils m'ont
recruté pour être leur support alors
support des astronomes qu'est ce que ça
veut dire
je me suis posé la question aussi au
début en fait support des astronautes ça
veut dire que mon rôle est de faciliter
la vie quotidienne des astronautes pour
que eux puissent se concentrer sur leurs
missions
alors il est difficile et c'est un peu
difficile d'imaginer puisque c'est plein
de petites choses différentes
c'est plus facile de le présenter de
façon par défaut on va dire un
astronaute lorsqu'il part dans l'espace
il doit être entraînée d'entraînement il
est en bonne santé
la partie médicale et puis fait plein
d'expériences scientifiques c'est un
laboratoire à la station spatiale
internationale
donc la partie scientifique
l'entraînement le médical le
scientifique
j'ai touche pas tout le reste
directement ou indirectement je pouvoir
avoir un impact dessus en tant que
support des astronautes
ça va de la nourriture spatiales jusqu'à
accompagner d'astronautes ou sa famille
à baïkonour
et maintenant ça fait maintenant six ans
que je travaille avec les astronautes et
j'ai passé quelques images et j'ai eu la
chance de vivre des moments
exceptionnels pour un passionné du
spatial je dois aller à baïkonour à
chaque fois qu'il y ait un lancement de
fusée soyouz avec des astronautes
européens et donc cette passion ne m'a
jamais quittée et j'ai envie de conclure
en dirait
je dirais par rapport à ce que j'ai pu
entendre juste avant que soient les
sandro qui parlait de la curiosité
humaine aller toujours plus loin
repousser les limites c'est ce que l'on
ne fait avec l'espace qui est la
frontière la limite actuelle de la
présence humaine mais j'aimerais aussi
rejoindre jean marc pour tout ce qui se
rapproche de l'écologie et se retourner
vers la terre c'est quelque chose qui
que les astronautes décrivent très
souvent qui a d'ailleurs un nom
maintenant qu'ils s'appellent lovers ou
effect c'est que en montant là haut les
astronautes se retourne et voit la terre
aussi fragile qu'elle est on l'a vu sur
la photo présentée plus tôt mais le
ressentir le rend cette urgence encore
plus forte
et comme me thomas pesquet qui en parle
très souvent il faut surtout bien faire
attention à notre vaisseau spatial
qu'est la terre et mais quand même je
pense cherché à aller plus loin un peu
dépasser nos limites et c'est tout pour
moi merci
[Applaudissements]